Hallelujah. Hallelujah.
Hallelujah.
question. [music]
Hey
How are you?
Are you married?
Hello. Hello. Am I on? Maybe I am.
Good. Yes. Okay. Excellent. I There were
like three mics up here, so I hopefully
got lucky with the right one. Hey, good
evening, tableablers,
tableists,
table. What else can we table eights?
[laughter]
It's so good to see all of you. I wasn't
able to be here for the Christmas
service. Um had somebody in the family
who was sick. Um so, it's so good to see
all of your faces tonight.
our first service of 2026. [music]
Welcome.
Happy New Year. Um, you are here on a
great night. And also, I [music] just
want to say hi to the people that are
tuning in online. Um, my name is Karen
Miner. Pronouns are she, her, [music]
and this is one of my favorite services
of the year. We get to hear stories from
people in our community. [music] And uh
it's just such a wonderful connecting
um Christc centered way to start off the
new year. So I'm really glad you're
here. I'm really glad I'm here and I'm
really glad we get to worship together
tonight. Um a couple of announcements.
This is the first Sunday of the [music]
month. And uh as is tradition around
here, first Sunday of every month, we go
out to eat after the service. Hat Creek
Burger Company off of Highway 78 and
Saxi. There's a playground for the kids.
The weather's pretty decent still, so
let's go eat after the service and
continue the conversation in the
community. Um, also, if you are feeling
fidgety or need something to do with
your hands during the service, we have
our accessibility bucket right over
there uh on the cabinet. Feel free to
take whatever you need. Um, just return
it [music] uh when you're done after the
service. Um, and I think that's it for
tonight. We're just kind of easing
[music] into the new year. I do want to
do a call to worship, which I do not
have memorized yet. [music] So, bear
with me. Let me grab that.
Let's take a breath together. [music]
Just arrive here now. Inhale in.
Exhale out.
Close your eyes if you like. [snorts]
Let yourself feel grounded
and [music] centered.
Let yourself be held tonight by the
peace and the grace [music] and the love
of God.
Now [music] we exit the kingdom of
noise, hurry, and productivity.
Now we enter the kingdom of silence,
stillness, and [music] simplicity.
A sacred space,
a place for prayer, worship, and [music]
adoration.
A place to to behold Christ, revelation
of God, heartbeat of creation.
Allow the [music] unforced rhythms of
grace to find you, to mend your heart.
May we all come home.
Thanks, Karen. We are so glad [music]
you guys are here. If y'all want to
stand with us, we're going to get
started with a few songs tonight.
This is a space that you are welcome.
your whole [music] story and all of your
gifts. Whether you are a singer or not a
singer, you are [music] a part of this
worship set with us. So, if you feel
comfortable singing out, [music] please
do so. If you want to sit and soak, you
can do that as well. Um, but we [music]
want it to be a holistic experience
where our our minds, our bodies, our
voices, um our hearts [music] are all
lifted up together in this room as it's
so rare that we get that gift in our um
fast-paced culture. [music] So let's
enjoy it and appreciate it tonight as we
worship a God who is with us and for us
[music]
through every [singing] battle
through every [music] heartbreak
through every [singing] circumstanc
Since
I [music] believe that you are my
fortress,
you are [singing] my portion.
You are [music] my hiding place.
I [music] believe you are the way,
[music] the truth,
the life.
I [music and singing] believe you are
the way,
[music] the truth,
and the [singing] life.
I [music] believe through every
blessing,
through every promise,
through every [music and singing]
breath I take.
I believe that you are providing me and
you are protecting
and you [music and singing] are the one
I love.
Oh, I believe [music] you are the way,
the truth, [music]
and the life. [singing]
[music]
I believe you are the way
and the truth, [music] the truth, the
life.
[music]
I believe you are.
Oh, [music]
you are.
[music]
And it's a new horizon.
And I'm set on you.
You meet me [music and singing] here
today.
Mercies that are new.
All my [music and singing] fears and
doubts,
they can all come true because [music]
they can't stay [singing] long. When I'm
here [music] with you,
it's a new [singing] horizon.
And I'm set on you.
[music] And you leave me here today.
Mercies that are new.
All my fears [music] is doubts.
Make it all come true [singing]
because they can't stay long [music]
when I believe you are the way,
the truth. [music and singing]
the life.
[music]
[singing] I believe you are the way,
[music] the truth, [singing]
and the life
[music and singing]
I believe you are. And it's a new
horizon
that I'm set [music] on you.
You'll leave me here today.
Mercy that I knew. [music]
All my fears and doubts.
[music] They can all come true because
they can't [singing] stay long when I
believe you are [music] the way
[singing]
and the truth
and [music] the life. [singing]
I believe you are. [music and singing]
Yeah, we believe.
All right, you kiddos are dismissed
[music] to go to kids ministry and your
teachers will meet you over there by the
doors. Thank you guys [music] for making
this service possible and giving our
kids a safe space to learn about the
love of God. So grateful for our
teachers and our helpers
in Ezekiel 36 it [music] says, "For I
will take you out of the nations and I
will gather you from all the countries
and bring you back into your own land.
[music] I'll sprinkle clean water on you
and you will be clean. I will cleanse
you from all your impurities, from all
your idols. I'll give [music] you a new
heart and I will put in you a new spirit
and I will remove from you your [music]
heart of stone and give you a heart of
flesh. You will [music] live in my land,
the land I gave your forefathers, and
[music] you will be my people, and I
will be your God.
We are [music and singing] leaving
crumbling buildings
full [music] of destinment.
[singing]
We are leaving
violent teachings
from those who [music and singing]
refuse to learn from the best of us.
[singing]
We are leaving
crumbling buildings [music]
full of [singing] dust and
[music] full of justice.
We are leaving [music]
violent [singing] teachings
from [music] those refuse to learn
[singing] from the best of us. [music]
We are [singing] leaving
[music] crumbling buildings
full of dust. [singing]
[music]
It's full of judment.
We are [music and singing] leaving
violent teaching [music]
from those [singing] refuse to learn
[music] from the best of us.
[music]
>> [music]
>> thinking he
[music]
seeking
a holy [music and singing] healing.
It's full of hope [singing] and it's
it's full of [music] justice.
And I've got a feeling [singing]
that we're in the middle of it.
I've got a feeling she'll see us
[singing] to the end of it. [music]
We are [singing] seeking
a [music] holy healing.
It's full [singing] of hope and it's
[music]
full of justice.
And I've got a feeling that [music]
we're in the middle of [singing] it.
I've got a feeling she'll see us
[singing] to the end. [music]
We are seeking
holy [music] healing.
It's full of hope and
full of [music and singing] justice.
And I've got a feeling that we're
[singing] in the [music] middle of it.
I've got a feeling she'll see us to the
end of [music] it.
Oh,
you'll see it through [music]
[singing] time. You'll see it through.
[music]
is so [music]
sweet to trust [singing] in Jesus.
Just to take him at his [singing] word,
just to rest
upon [music]
his [singing]
promise,
and to know
the [singing] saith [music] the Lord.
Jesus, [singing]
Jesus,
[music] how I trust [singing] him. How I
prove
him more [singing]
[music] and
Jesus.
Jesus,
precious
[music] Jesus.
Oh, [singing] for grace
to trust him [singing]
more. [music]
>> Jesus,
[singing] Jesus,
how [music] I trust him. How [singing] I
proved
him [music]
and
Jesus [singing]
Jesus [music]
preious [singing]
Jesus. [music]
Oh, for grace
to trust [singing]
him [music]
more.
Oh, [singing]
for grace
to trust him
more.
God, as [music] we go into a new year
full of new possibilities, we remember
that you [music]
are the same God
who's held our hand through the trials,
the struggles, [music]
the heartbreak,
the pain,
and you will continue to see us through.
You will continue
to work on our heart of stone and
[music] replace it with a heart of
flesh.
You will continue to bring light into
[music] darkness
and healing and hope where there was
loss,
where there has been damage. God,
you bring your repair.
We trust you to continue [music] that
good work in our hearts. We trust you to
make us into a new creation.
God, would we make space and room for
you and your work in our lives
in Jesus name?
Amen.
All right. Would you guys turn to the
person on your right and left and say,
"The peace of Christ be with you." And
then you may be seated.
All right.
Well, it is story Sunday,
first Sunday of the year. And yeah, I'm
excited. Glad to be with you all. My
name is Brett. I'm the pastor here. And
uh yeah, a joy joy to be with you on
this special day and uh and just uh to
welcome you uh into this space into this
new year uh full of possibility and and
uh hope for what Christ will do among us
and as always want to welcome those join
us online. Um yeah, love y'all lots as
well. So um bas basically we kind of
have this value for um really just
opening up space to hear from people. We
always do it at least the very first
Sunday of the year and then sometimes
kind of throughout we'll sporadically do
it on occasion. Uh and just kind of
there's something about uh kind of
honoring people's story, honoring their
journeys and uh and really giving our
attention to to folks and uh and in a
way of kind of being able to track not
only each other just relationally but
even being able to kind of track like
what is what is God up to in in uh
people's lives even in sometimes kind of
unexpected ways. And having said that,
it's not um even necessarily always like
uh some neat and tidy bow on it, you
know? I mean, these aren't always
stories of just kind of like victory and
we're just going from one success to the
next, you know, or something. This is
that's that's not really the point,
isn't to um uh this isn't like a promo
or like a highlight reel for the table,
you know, or something. Um uh this is
really just yeah, listening to people
and uh and hearing uh the journey that
they've they've been on. So, uh, with
that in mind, I want to invite up
Tiffany and Jared Louderdermilk on onto
the stage. Y'all give them a hand as
they come forward.
[applause and cheering]
How about the middle?
>> All right. So, the louder milks
>> don't have to do announcements today.
>> You don't have to do announcements, my
friend. We uh in fact Jared was
scheduled and we're like yeah maybe
that's not best to let's let's just
leave you just a few just just one thing
to do you know um but the the ladder if
you haven't had a chance to get to know
them wonderful people one thing I love
about them is I mean they have like a
lot of the more I've gotten to know them
I've seen some of the similarities but
initially what strikes me about them
like they're very different in that
Jared is like the extroverts extrovert
he you know what I mean he just all the
people all the time and Tiffany is not
the extrovert's extrovert, you know,
just like quiet and all that, but um
yeah, so I'm grateful I'm grateful for
both of you sharing. I'm particularly
grateful to Tiffany for her willingness
to like jump up. I know this is like way
outside the comfort zone, but even
Jared, too, I mean, this isn't like
necessarily always just super easy, get
in front of everyone and, you know,
share your story. So, um we're really
really grateful for y'all. So, um, they
Oh, and I should mention, too, they've
been, uh, kind of, uh, together. Oh, was
it married 21 years or together 21
years?
>> It's been a while.
>> Married 20 years this year.
>> Married this month. Uh, together 26.
>> 26. Okay, that's what it is. Yeah. So, I
mean, this is like y'all y'all have been
together a while. Y'all I'm not saying
you're getting old. I'm just saying
you've been together. That's That's
awesome.
>> We're getting old.
>> Yeah.
>> It is indeed not my first rodeo.
>> Yeah. [laughter]
and uh and then attending the table for
the last two and a half years and y'all
live in in Saxi. So um all right. So you
both grew up in fairly, you know, kind
of religiously conservative environments
to maybe put it mildly. Um so just what
was that like and how did it uh shape
shape you as a person?
So, we were talking about this this last
week, and
one of the things that is very similar
about the houses they we grew up in is
the dynamic of
one person is right. Everyone else
agrees with them whether you like it or
not. Um
that is I've come to realize that is a
very
Christian evangelical kind of
perspective. Not every house has that.
Didn't know that growing up. Um but when
Jared and I got together, we both had
come from houses where there was a lot
of fighting. There was a lot of
resentment. There was a lot of
[sighs]
>> tension.
>> Tension. There you go. Um, and we didn't
want that. Like, we didn't have the
words that we have now for it. But 25
years ago, we were both like, I don't
want to live my life screaming at each
other. I don't want to live my life
resenting you because you made me do a
thing that I very clearly didn't want to
do. And so, we just said, "Let's not do
we we can just not do that, right? Like,
that's allowed." And so, we didn't. and
we made it a really concerted effort to
not do that in our life together.
>> Yeah, I would agree. I think we both the
Christian evangelical
um hierarchy system of
obedience
followed with and that being kind of
going all the way up the chain to the to
dad and then like all those things.
Um
but there was no space to have
discussion.
Um, and I think that's a thing that
that's how that's turned into for us is
nothing is very rarely is something a
like a big decision. Like sure, if you
don't have the spoons to figure out what
what's for dinner, then I'll figure out
dinner. We don't have to discuss that.
But um
the big things in life are discussions
that happen. They're not things that are
mandated. Yeah.
>> Was there, you know, you kind of
mentioned wanting a different household
and a different kind of marital dynamic
and uh was there kind of a single moment
that started to, you know, that stands
out as like, oh, that was like the
moment that really started to shift my
my kind of, you know, religious
spiritual trajectory or, you know, was
it kind of a like a series of small like
micro shifts through the through the
years? Um, like which one kind of
mattered most to you? I mean obviously
to some degree maybe both those were
there but which one what would you say
was kind of the more the experience
>> um
in our relationship
very early on we had one or two kind of
bigger fights and
you know had one of those where we went
to bed angry and then were mad at each
other for like three days and it was
real ugly and awful. Um, and I just
like I know to me it was I don't want to
I don't want this. I don't want to feel
this way. I don't want to live this way.
There has to be something better. Um,
but that part was very much sort of a
gradual shift and kind of just learning
how to do it because we had not seen it
in action. Um, personally for my
deconstruction, for me there was one one
moment we were um doing training to do
foster care. And in that training um
there was a lot of conversation about
cultural differences and understanding
like the culture of your own house. And
we had said, "Oh yeah, we're definitely
open to kids from any background, any
race." Um and and our agency, bless
them, they were they said, "Okay, if
you're going to say that and you're both
white, then you need to learn some
things because there's probably stuff
you don't know." And so I started
learning from
transracial adopes, so people who had
been adopted into a house that was not
the same race as them. um and learning
from um adoptive families where the
parents were black or Hispanic or not
white. And very quickly my eyes were
opened to not just the state of racial
relations in America, but also how
involved the church was in the mess that
we are in.
Um and I was like once you see that, you
can't unsee it. So for me it was that
was the very quick oh no I've fallen off
a cliff and nothing else will ever be
the same. Um
yeah
um my deconstruction was
more gradual. Um I tried for a long time
to figure out how to rebuild it. Um I
compared to a Jenga game very often. um
like my spiritual journey in general
just as like a Jenga tower and you start
poking a block and you put it on top and
you take another one and sooner or later
I got to the point that I removed enough
blocks it was no longer like the next
block became
the thing that it was like oh I have to
do like one of those YouTube tricks
where like I punch it out like really
quickly and the whole thing just drops
and stays together or I don't and
literally will all fall apart. And I
tried it and it all fell apart. Um
[laughter]
but um there are some key like I know
some of the blocks specifically like
when things happened like when things
started to shift in my life in general
about things that made me get out of the
Navy about things that moved me in a
direction away from evangelicalism.
You know, sometimes people have kind of
described deconstruction as a bit like
being uh going through a desert. And by
the way, we're throwing around that term
a lot just for those who may be
unfamiliar. So deconstruction is to kind
of sum it up, it's it's kind of a
process of rethinking often questioning
kind of inherited beliefs. the often in
our context in the church it's like
theology and doctrines and things uh and
some of which maybe you find to be quite
beautiful and helpful and then others or
maybe even many of which you end up
feeling like you need to jettison um so
that's kind of what we're referring to
there but um so that process like as you
mentioned with the Jangar it's not
always this isn't easy you know this
isn't for most of us who've been on that
journey not an easy journey um so it can
feel like a desert has there been for
you kind of like a person or a book or a
place that's been kind of water like in
that in that desert.
Um, I think the thing I've learned
through deconstruction, I don't know
that there have been way points for me
that have helped. Um, and it started
with things like I I read a book uh by
Pete Ends, um, the Bible tells me so.
That was just kind of eye opening for
me, a different perspective on the way
the Bible was taught to me my entire
life. um
was like the first one. There's been
some others of like coming into contact
with Richard Roar and Brian McLaren
um and Sarah Bessie. Um I don't need a
book promo anything, but um
where the they got me into the path that
now has me into what I think the bigger
thing I've learned out of all of it is
the importance of not letting myself be
isolated with it.
um that the bigger thing that you need
is a community than you need and not to
not to knock Brett's love of silent
passionate quietness. Um
but the thing for me is being engaged
with a community because that's where
I'm going to see God. Um at least for
me.
>> Yeah. Jared and I have email strands
going back and forth where I'm like,
"Dude, you should really try to sit like
in silence for a while." He's like,
"Buddy, you should hang out with more
people." And I'm like, "I [laughter]
don't know.
>> We both probably need to move towards
the other little bits." Yeah.
>> Yeah, we do.
>> I've set in some silence.
>> Yeah.
>> If there is a gospel of Jared is you
should spend time with more people.
[laughter]
>> Yeah. But Tiffany, how about you for the
the water in the desert?
>> Um,
in the long run, it's actually similar
answer that I needed to know that other
people were going through it. other
people were also asking hard questions.
Um I found that on social media, Tik
Tok, Instagram, like I found um honestly
April Joy and um
se there were several accounts where
people were kind of just being silly,
but it was coming from a hey, this thing
that we lived with our whole lives is
kind of absurd. Did you notice that it
was kind of absurd? Um, and that that
gave me a really nice in to all the
other people that are talking about,
hey, this is not the only way to think
about faith and spirituality and even
this specific faith. This is not the
only way. Um, the other thing I found
was in that because my understanding of
racial stuff and my understanding of
the evangelical church were so parallel
like that. both of those deconstructions
were so parallel. A lot of what I found
was um
looking for intentionally looking for
teachers and perspectives of Christian
faith that were not white American
Christian faith. So looking for teachers
from Europe and Africa and Asia and
looking for people who don't look like
me and how do they see how do they read
what's in the Bible? How do they
interpret those scriptures that we've
been that I've heard my whole life and
come with one specific translation? But,
you know, if I'm coming from an
oppressed people or if if the
perspective is from somebody who's been
colonized, what does that do to those
same verses? Um, so looking at that kind
of perspective was really helpful for me
of like, oh, there's a whole world here
that I just literally have never seen
and I can explore it as much as I want
to.
>> Yeah. Would
with your kind of uh journey in mind is
the language of deconstruction
which when I think of uh I want to kind
of contrast like deconstruction with
evolution. Some people describe their
journey as a little more deconstruction
like Jangga tower, you know, like I'm
really poking at stuff. It's like very
intentional and often quite intense. Uh
as opposed to like an evolution. It's a
kind of gradual unfolding. It's a little
more gentle. If you had to choose a
metaphor, which one do you like and why?
>> It was not gentle. There was no gentle.
Um, I told a friend several years ago,
this process for me has been a bit like
like I've learned as you grow up, you're
handed things, beliefs, values, ideas,
and you're told either by explicit words
or by the way it's handed to you, "This
is precious. Hold it carefully."
At this point in my life, I have had to
take all of those things that I'm
holding that are all precious and that
I'm gonna drop because there's just too
many of them. And I've had to
intentionally put them down,
stop and examine each one and decide,
is this actually precious to me? Does it
mean anything to me at all? Does it have
any value left? Um, you know, what is it
what is it doing for me? Is this the
kind of thing that I just want to toss
because it's not any good anymore? Or is
it like, oh, this might be useful. I'm
going to throw it in my backpack and
just keep it maybe sometimes. Or am I
going to continue to hold it like it's
precious? And a lot of those things I
feel like were very breakable and I
ended up just throwing them on the
ground and now I have all these little
pieces that I'm pulling together and
turning into a mosaic that looks like
what I want it to look like. So,
not gentle, but also not fast.
So, whatever that looks like,
>> um,
I would put mine more on the slow,
intentional
track. I I took at it with an attitude
of trying to fix it first. Like that's
one of like I can rebalance everything.
I can figure it out. I'm a smart guy.
I just need to read more. I just need to
do more. And eventually that came to the
point that I couldn't do anymore. And I
think what I've the the Jenga tower
thing is I've realized
I now have a bunch of blocks that I can
build. I won't say anything with, but
like I have a lot more parameters. And
to Tim Tiffy's
metaphor, it's it is looking at things
and seeing what is of value and what is
going to what can serve me or what how
can something help me and how can Um,
and maybe that thing's not right now,
but some things I may need to hold on
to. So, but it was definitely more it
was slow for me because I didn't I think
that's the other thing. I didn't want it
to fail, right? I spent a lot of time
trying to rescue it.
>> I think I was very ready to just smash
the whole thing. [laughter]
>> Yeah. Yeah. What's um kind of maybe an
insight or something you've you've
gleaned uh from this whole process that
has um like improved your life, you
know, something something from the
journey that you you would not want to
give back. Like you look at it, you say
that actually even though this is like
hard as hell in ways but it was I really
learned
I think the thing I wouldn't like the
thing I've wouldn't give like out you're
asking like what I wouldn't give back
out of like the deconstruction process.
>> Um
I would not give back
the p like I'm gonna how do I say this?
I don't think I'll ever let anybody put
blinders on me again. Like not that I'm
giving something back as so much as it
is is like I'm never going to give up my
my pers my my open perspective now.
things are no longer like, it's funny,
years ago, we went to a really, we lived
in Connecticut and we wound up in this
little church that was marvelous and
wonderful and great and really kind of
similar to this place except smaller.
Um, but the first time we went, we
walked in and I was erased these
simplies of God. I spiritfilled, etc.
We walked in and there's like it's in
this little kind of storefront area, but
they've got the windows covered up and
like, okay, you walk in and there's this
room to the right and it says detox
room. And then there was like candles
and incense burning. And I remember
looking at Tiffany and being like,
I we say the word, I'm out. Either one
of us.
>> If this goes sideways,
>> if this goes sideways, if this is if
this is the devil, we're gone.
[laughter]
Um, and just having that concept of
like, oh, this can't possib Like
everything red flagged to me initially
and it wound up not being red flags. It
wound up being a really great community
to be in, but
of having that of not just immediately
making judgment on things. I think
that's what I would
>> Yeah. say
>> in that place they intentionally pulled
in traditions from different different
kinds of Christianity like oh you this
is a prayer corner and this is incense
and you can light candles and and things
that we had never really been exposed
to. So for them them to bring those
pieces in
felt even that felt like oh this is this
is too far and honestly that may have
been the beginning of the way way way
way before we got to the cliff and fell
off of it. That may have been the
beginning. But um yeah, I think
for me the big thing that has shifted
that
is really only in the last year, maybe
two years, um is I was raised in the
tradition that
at at our core we are sinners and evil
and that a person is a bad person and
has to be saved in order to be good. And
I have completely gone a 180 on that. I
now believe that if I am made in the
image of God, then I am then I contain a
spark of the divine and therefore I
can't be bad. I have to be good at my
core. Um and I would at this point that
is that is the thing that continues to
sustain me no matter what is
my
base instinct is for good always.
This may tie in, but last question.
What's one thing your journey has taught
you about love that you didn't know
before?
>> How much self-compassion it takes to
love? Well,
>> can you say more about that?
It wasn't until I learned to love myself
and to be to give myself compassion that
I was able to soften enough to give room
for everyone else.
And love doesn't like
if I'm not just performing and saying,
"Oh, I'm doing the right thing,
therefore I love you." If I actually
want to truly love people, I have to be
able to see the humanity in them, which
means I have to see it in myself.
>> Yeah. What's one thing that your
journey's taught you about love that you
didn't know before?
something I didn't know before about
love before this journey. Um,
I don't think I realized
how
um
how universal it is
to
to Tiffany's point about the divine
spark, but it's like I didn't realize
that it was
as deep as it was like how deep it
really is in things that when you get to
it, it's when you really start to look
at the the words and the actions of
things that love is really the best
measuring stick for things.
um that you can't tactically analyze
something. You can't when it comes to
your humanity that it has to start with
love and that it has to
like the things we say that we do for
love sometimes are not
actually rooted in love. They're rooted
in other things and how we're striving
to get to that kind of love, but we do
it in
We do it inadequately sometimes.
>> Well, Louder Milks, thank you. Thank you
for sharing.
>> You're welcome.
>> Y'all give them a hand.
[applause]
>> All right, the barns.
All right. Well, thank you all for for
sharing uh having having the courage to
um you know, so the this is uh Anna and
Becky Barnes, and they've been married
for 11 years and attending the table for
about three years. uh that might they
have a little bit different timetables
which maybe will come out as they share
their story and uh something you should
know about them I would say there's
these they're like very kind of behind
the scenes folks in a lot of ways but
they're like behind the scenes in a way
that makes the table possible so they
like host and lead a meetup uh they
serve on the tech team back here and
just you know those folks that are just
like present and faithful and showing up
in a way that's um we're very very
grateful for. So, um, let's just start
with, uh, how did y'all meet and what's
one detail about your kind of early in
your relationship that people wouldn't
necessarily guess?
>> Yeah. So, uh, we met online, uh, on
OkayCid.
We were both in our mid30s. Um, and so,
you know, because
um because we were older, we kind of
already knew what we wanted uh in in a
partner and um and we really connected
quickly and so things kind of kind of
went pretty fast, but um
let's see. Sorry, looking at my notes
here.
>> [clears throat]
>> Yeah, just we had a lot of shared values
and um it just we were fast friends.
>> Yeah,
>> I think Yeah,
>> one thing I guess people probably
wouldn't guess about us is that we both
grew up with very different
communication styles. Um so learning how
to communicate with each other was very
challenging early on.
Yeah, I I can remember early on
um my my style would be just I would
shut down. Um and it took months of Anna
encouraging me to tell me what's wrong,
what's going on. Um and me finally
trusting her with that. And I remember
we were in the car going somewhere and
she she asked me what was wrong and and
I just told her. And then you like,
okay, I'm sorry. I didn't mean to do
that or that wasn't my heart. And then I
realized I don't have to be mad about
this the rest of the day. This is so
freeing. I love [laughter] this.
>> Like you can live like this. You can.
>> Yeah. So,
>> but uh you know, Anna made it a safe
place for me to mess up and say the
wrong thing and tell her how I'm feeling
and
we just learn together.
>> If you um if you had to kind of
summarize the faith of your childhood um
or even kind of maybe early up through
early adulthood or something in a single
word, what would that word be and why?
>> I think for me it would be
transactional. That's kind of the word
that comes to mind. Um, I grew up uh and
similar to what uh Tiffany was talking
about where um it wasn't okay to like
ask questions. It was just this is what
the preacher says, so that's that's
gospel, you know. And um and you know, I
was we were told like that Jesus was
loving and relational, but the way it
was practiced and and lived out was more
transactional. Like if you had enough
things on your on your sheet, you know,
then [clears throat] God was okay with
you. But if you didn't, then it's like
you're you know, your account's
overdrawn. You're you're out of here,
buddy, you know.
>> Um so yeah, that's that's kind of a in a
nutshell how I grew up.
>> I think the word that I would pick would
be conscientious. Um my as a kid, my
faith was innocent and sincere and um I
really I wanted to love God and I wanted
to do the right thing and um I think I
took things literally. And so a lot of
times I would think something small was
a sin when it really wasn't. Um and so
as I got older, um that same sincerity
turned into anxiety, I think. Uh and
overspiritualization.
Um I kind of I I became very per
perfectionist. I mean like messing up
the word perfectionist like
Okay. Uh, [laughter] I wasn't just
trying to love God. I was I was trying
not to fail him and not mess up. Um,
>> so this question is for Anna. Um,
looking back kind of on your life, when
did you first, you know, kind of suspect
like I'm I'm not I'm not quite like uh
some of the other people around me seem
to be and and kind of what were the kind
of concrete circumstances, you know,
around around that?
>> Yeah. So, you know, one of the things I
want to name right up front, and you
kind of alluded to this in the
beginning, was that this doesn't fit in
my story doesn't fit into a neat box.
There was no aha moment or where I a
moment where I just knew, you know, it
was um I for a long time I just assumed
that um because I it didn't fit in any
box like my experience didn't count like
it wasn't valid.
But, you know, I would have to say
growing up what I did have was this
constant sense of like failing at the
things that the boys around me seem to
just be able to do naturally without
even thinking about it. Um, and it was
like everybody else had been handed a
script and were was able to follow it,
but uh I spent most of my life trying to
like compensate and figure out what I
was supposed to be doing. Um, and I also
learned uh early on that certain parts
of me uh weren't safe. I I can remember
an early memory I had was um trying to
play dress up with my sister and her
friends and all the adults laughing at
me for doing that. And um so I didn't
really understand intellectually what
was going on there because I was too
young. But my body understood that this
part of you is not safe. Um and so you
know I had to hide it. Um, you know, of
course over time that turns into just
exhaustion. Um, always scanning the
room, always performing,
uh, always bracing for the next
situation where I'd have to get it
right. Um, and you know, um, I didn't
really even have language to explain it,
what was happening to me, but even if I
did, I wouldn't have felt safe using
that language.
And looking back, uh, I can see what I
was really longing for was like
permission to be soft and feminine. Um,
but it it was in a world where, um,
softness wasn't uh, allowed to belong to
me.
And,
>> [snorts]
>> um, my early 20s, I I joined the Navy in
an attempt to try to like force this
some version of masculinity upon me.
>> Toughen up.
>> Yeah. And um yeah, that was a that was a
disaster. [laughter]
I quickly washed out of boot camp with
anxiety and panic attacks and um yeah,
it just was not for me. Um
in my early 30s, I did come close to
like some clarity of what was happening.
Um but um I quickly kind of just shut
the door in that because of a lot of
shame. Um and u so I you know I shut
that door so hard that it it became
almost like I was it was denial you know
really like and so when I met Becky I I
genuinely didn't feel like I was hiding
something from her it was in my mind
resolved you know um but what what I
looking back what I really was doing was
I just learned how to bury questions um
instead of answering them.
Um, so I I share all that this in this
way because I know there are people who
feel pressured to have a clean dramatic
story or whatever about their faith or
their identity or whatever. Um, and some
of us just don't. Uh, some of us find
clarity slowly through unlearning and
frankly through survival.
Was there um well what was it eventually
like you mentioned kind of you had
moments where it's like oh I think maybe
but then you would shut the door again.
What what eventually led you to a place
of like kind of um you know really
coming out and uh and then how did that
like what was the experience like of
starting to share that with Becky and
you know start start that kind of road?
>> Yeah, honestly you know it it wasn't
like a moment of clarity for me. It was
more like just pure exhaustion.
Um
uh I had spent most of my life assuming
that if I tried hard enough then things
would just work out. I would uh
eventually resolve this mismatch that I
feel felt on the inside. Um
and you know it turned out what I wasn't
I wasn't really like revealing a secret
to Becky. It was more like I was
discovering one.
Um, and you know, discovery is messy,
you know, and uh, it's slow and there's
no certainty attached to it. So, you
know, telling Becky was one of the
hardest things I ever had to do because
I wasn't coming to her with this thing I
had figured out. I was coming to her
with this messy thing that I would that
was still in progress, you know, and
knowing that even just telling her that
would disrupt our entire lives and, you
know, disrupt Becky's idea of where she
saw, you know, our life ending up. Um
uh but it turned out, you know,
coming to her early instead of waiting
until I had it figured out was exactly
what we needed because if I hadn't it,
she wouldn't have had the time to to try
to adjust and to wrap her mind around
it. Um and I don't think our marriage
would have would have survived it. Um
and um you know, of course, that was
just the beginning of a a long and
painful
uh stretch. We're both just trying to
figure out what it what it meant for I
was trying to figure out what it meant
for me and for us. Um you know and and
in a lot of ways we still don't have it
figured out. You know, we're still
working through that.
>> Um this one's for Becky. So, what was
the very first thought or feeling that
went through your mind um when Anna
began, you know, to come out to you as
trans? Like what what was what was the
experience um like there? So, I think my
first reaction was confusion. I can
remember sitting in the car because
that's where she told me. Um, [snorts]
and not really having a framework for
what she just said. Um, and so I think I
just didn't believe it because I I just
I didn't have the words, the framework,
the ideas to connect those dots. Um,
after that came fear and grief. Um and
then a lot of praying and fasting. We uh
we both grew up in the evangelical world
and um
you know I think that we
you know we weren't super
we weren't people who were into fasting
uh and doing those things. Um but this
was like
oh my god what are we going to do? like
we've we've got to do something drastic.
And
[sighs]
you know,
what do you do when you pray and you
fast and you cry and you
um
you do all the things and the things
don't work. Um
that's where we found ourselves. Um,
and we found ourselves
in the I found myself in the midst of
people who had
taught me to love like Jesus.
And you know, when you get married,
divorce isn't in your vocabulary. It's
not in the dictionary anymore.
And you have those same people
not telling you that you should get
divorced, but
you know,
I just I know that's what they wanted.
Um,
so
thankfully, we have a we each have a our
own therapist and we have a couple's
therapist. And uh, one of the things
they told our couple's therapist told
us, you know, as you extend the circle,
it's going to get harder. And um it did.
Um
and I think uh also the months that
followed, one of the uh metaphors that I
really clung to was I felt like I was in
a pitch black room and I couldn't find
the light switch
and I was stubbing my toes and like just
all the things. Um, but there were some
people who had flashlights
and I knew that I or I I had to learn to
trust them. Uh, those people were our
therapists. Um, our our couple's
therapist. Um, people here at church and
um our meetup. I I I
don't know if we'd still be married if
it weren't for our meetup. um they held
us uh in a time when still even still um
so anyway um
I think grief grief has been one of the
big key things for me uh learning how to
deal with that feeling bad about
grieving feeling like if I cry or if I
grieve I'm
not betraying you but I'm not being nice
to you. Um, but you know, there's a
sense that I
there's a sense that my husband died,
but he didn't. And it's really confusing
because there's that grief,
but then
the person that I love is still here.
It's the same person. and it's the
person that I fell in love with. That
hasn't changed. The thoughtfulness, the
heart, the kindness.
Um, so in those dark times, it just
really messed with my head um of just
confusion.
Um, but I guess the thing that never
went away was just my love for Anna.
So,
>> um, well, kind of last question, this
ties in with what you just named. It's
um kind of what's what's one thing
through this journey um that it's taught
you about love that you didn't know
before?
>> I guess I I would have to say that um
I've learned that love isn't certainty.
It's about presence. And
um it's about choosing honesty over
comfort and staying in the room even
when honesty costs something
because if we're not honest with each
other,
then
how can we how can we be vulnerable at
the level that we need to be to stay
connected and and love?
Um, I think for me
I as I thought about this question,
there's there's two things and they're
both equal and how do I pick? Um, but I
think the thing that it has taught me
about love is that two things can be
true at the same time. Um,
I can deeply love Anna and I can feel
hurt and or angry. Uh, I can be
committed and still scared. I can want
to stay and still grieve what I thought
things would look like.
Um, I think holding that tension has
been it's been incredibly
uncomfortable, but it's real.
um
uh not learning to shut down or choose
one feeling over the other. Learning to
stay present in that tension of
I love you, but I'm really mad at you
right now. Or
I really I I I'm committed to this, but
I do not see the way forward.
God, you've got to make the way forward.
Um,
yeah. I think just, you know, staying
present in that tension is what I'm
[snorts] learning about love right now.
>> Thank you both so much for sharing. It's
beautiful, beautiful journey. You'll
give them a hand.
[applause]
Oh, it's beautiful. Huh. Beautiful.
Beautiful. God's God's faithful, you
know, just to meet us wherever wherever
we are. Wherever we are on that on that
journey. So, I hope there was things for
you to take away, things you resonated
with, um things that that spoke to you.
And uh even though it's, you know, of
course folks with their own journeys,
you know, and there's things that are
specific to them, but I hope you can
kind of resonate with so much of what
they shared. So, uh we're going to
transition now to communion. And there's
just something so helpful about
reentering on Christ uh like we do
pretty much uh every Sunday here at the
table. And uh so for those who are maybe
aren't familiar with this this practice
uh Christ had a a final meal with his
disciples and at that meal he held the
loaf of bread and he broke it and he
said take this and eat it. This is my
body. It's broken for you. And then he
held up a cup of wine and he said take
this drink it. This is my blood. It's
shed for you. whenever you eat this
bread, whenever you drink this cup,
remember me. So, it's this point of
connection. It's this point of of kind
of intimacy of uh of taking in Christ,
of um being kind of both consuming
Christ and being consumed uh by uh the
God who is love. So, that's kind of what
we're participating in. Um you should
know we practice what's called an open
table. So, you know, if you're here
tonight and you'd like to participate,
you're free to do that regardless, you
know, of your like exact, you know,
theological Christian beliefs or, you
know, whatever. If there's something in
you that wants to connect with Christ,
then then feel free to come forward and
participate. Uh, you should know the red
is wine, the white is grape juice, and
uh you can just partake whenever and
however you'd like. Some folks like to
come and kneel here at the front, others
return to their seat to partake, but you
no one will lead you through the exact
moment of taking. uh you can just do
that uh as you feel led. So this is the
table, not of the church, but of the
Lord. And it's made ready for those who
love him and for those who want to love
him more. So come, come, you who have
much faith and you who have little, you
who have been here often and you who
have not been here long, you who have
tried to follow and you who feel like
you failed, come. Come because it's the
Lord Jesus himself invites you and it's
his will that those who want to meet him
should meet him here. Come to the table.
>> [snorts]
>> It's a new [singing and music] horizon
and I'm set on you.
You meet me here [music] today with
mercies that are new.
All my fears and doubts, [music]
they can all come true
because they can't stay long
[music and singing]
when I'm here with you. Y'all sing that
with us. It's a new horizon
and I'm [singing] set on you. [music]
You meet me here today with mercies that
are [music] new.
All my fears and [singing] doubts,
[music] they can all come to you because
they can't stay [singing] long. When I
believe you are the way, [singing]
the truth [music]
is
the life.
I [singing] believe [music] you are the
way
and the truth
in the life.
I [music] believe you are.
We believe [singing]
you are.
[music]
Thank you all so much for being here
tonight. Uh [music] thanks again to
Jared and Tiffany, Anna and Becky.
[snorts]
Your presence among us, your
vulnerability, your openness,
your courage was a gift. It was such a
beautiful expression of love. So, thank
you guys. So glad you're part of the
table community. Um, if you're visiting
with us, thank you so much for being
here tonight. Uh, there's going to be a
QR code that comes up on the screen. Uh,
we would love for you to fill out the
visitor card uh either uh digitally or
we also have cards on the table over
there that you can fill out. Just drop
in the box. Uh, we would love to thank
you for being here tonight and uh get to
know you a little bit and give you some
information about our community. Um,
that QR code is great. It tells you all
about our meetups. You can give um you
can get the worship playlist. Lots of
cool stuff with the QR code. So, feel
feel free to scan that. Uh, don't forget
about Hat Creek tonight. Right after
we're done here, we'll head over to Hat
Creek Burger Company SE off of 78 and
Saxi. We would love to have you there.
Um, and lastly, uh, I'd love to send you
into your week and into your year ahead,
uh, with a benediction. And so if you
are able and comfortable doing so,
please stand to your feet.
You can hold your hands out
uh in a posture of receiving or you can
just open your heart to these words that
I believe are true for each and every
one of you.
You are a child of God.
This is true on your best day and it's
true on your worst day.
So, as you go into your week and year
ahead with its yet to be determined
highs and lows and everything in
between,
go filled with the assurance that you
are loved, you are worthy, and you are
accepted
just as you are.
and go filled with God's Holy Spirit and
the desire to extend these same gifts
of grace, compassion, and love to
everyone you come in contact with. Be
blessed.
Have a good night. We'll see you at Hat
Creek in a few minutes. Good night.
[music and singing]
>> And I'm set on you.
You [music] meet me here today with
mercies that are new.
All my fears and doubts,
they can all come true
[music and singing]
because they can stay long when I
believe [music] you are the way,
[singing]
the truth of
the love. [singing]
I believe you are the way
and [music] the true love
[singing]
[music]
I believe you are.
Nice job, Miles. That
>> was good.
>> Thank you.